So years ago, when I was a high school student,
I walked away from Christianity and went down
a whole other path for a good long time.
The primary reason that I walked away is because I had questions and I had doubts.
And you've gotten up to this point now where not only have you have all this content
and we've talked about love and we've talked about the power of questions and
the power of conversation.
But somewhere in there at some point, questions from others,
information from other people,
going to college,
all kinds of different things are going to be coming at your students,
causing doubt.
What happens when they doubt?
See I walked away because I thought well because I was doubting, I asked a question,
I was told not to ask the questions.
I was told to just believe.
I was told to just have faith and I didn't know what that even meant and I just
couldn't
figure it all out so I just said enough and I walked away.
The statistics are still out there and they're still pretty prevalent that a large
majority
of students leave youth group after high school and there's a whole bunch of reasons
for that.
One of them is because when they have doubts, they're not getting answered.
So this is an opportunity to open it up to your students and say listen, I get it.
I know you have doubts.
Maybe share some of your own and that's okay.
Let's talk about it.
Let's make sure this is an open forum.
We talked weeks ago at the very beginning of this process.
The idea of having an open communication and having a youth group that was very
authentic and very open and invited the difficult questions.
We talked about that those difficult questions were going to come.
They're probably going to come even more now because sometimes the more information
that
you have, the more questions you have as a result.
So invite those in.
Invite those doubts.
If students are not sure about Jesus, not sure about the existence of God, not sure
about the biblical text, not sure about evil and pain and suffering, not sure about
any of the things that we've talked about and maybe some things that we haven't
talked
about because there's a whole bunch of cultural issues that step into this that you
have to
help students navigate.
And that's where helping students navigate doubt is an incredibly important thing,
an
important tool at actually furthering their faith because as they get those things
answered, as they feel free to express those doubts, that tells them that as leaders
we understand and that we've been there and that it's okay and we're going to walk
with you through those.
So for the introduction activity this week,
we asked students literally to write down
one question that they've been wrestling with.
Now you might as a large group activity, you know,
you might actually take and compile
some of those.
You might do a Q&A session.
I find Q&A sessions to be incredibly helpful.
I open up the floor to students and just let them ask whatever they want.
And yeah, you get some funny ones.
I get a lot of like dinosaur questions and some interesting ones, you know,
about Adam
and Eve and some interesting, and those can be fun.
You can play around with those a little bit and have some fun with it.
But at the same time, some really good and profound questions will come up and the
advantage to that is that if one student asks a question and another student's
afraid
to ask the same question, the student that was afraid gets their question answered.
That can be an incredibly important and powerful tool.
So I would encourage you to maybe do that this week or find a way to incorporate
many
questions into your large group time.
And then during small group time you can drill those questions down a little bit
deeper.
But make sure as you do that that your small group leaders are adequately prepared
to handle some of the questions.
Based on your situation and the leadership that you have in place and the volunteers
that you have in place, just make sure that they are equipped to properly answer.
And that remind them that it's okay, that they don't have an answer.
To say I don't have an answer and to write those questions down and bring them back
and find a way to get those questions answered specifically.
Another important, powerful tool is your storyteller this week.
To have somebody in front of your students that has actually expressed out and
walked
through it in some way, shape or form can be incredibly important.
That story, whatever they've been through will resonate, I'm sure,
with many of your students.
So make sure that you don't need to find the best story or the biggest story
or the most compelling story, but just so that students can see that, hey,
I'm not the only one going through this.
And I'm not the only one that has, I'm not the only student that's dealing with this
and I'm not the only person that's ever dealt with this and people have got through
it.
Because some students might just have little questions here and there.
Other students might be at a significant crisis of faith in their lives
where they need serious direction.
And after all that you've gone through in this study,
some of those things may start to be, you know,
coming up to the surface a little bit.
So remind your students that no matter their questions, no matter the doubts,
God can handle it and that He has given us everything we need
to be entirely confident of who He is, who Jesus is, and what our salvation means.